they tried from ladies your way me
personally I think so there have been
several cities Miami Miami yes
[Laughter]
we're in the finals one year it was
during the playoffs another year going
to the front desk finding what room I'm
in wow I gotta change the name of my
hotel room there were girls knocking on
your hotel knocking on the hotel door
captain no but it was like but again I'm
looking at them
open the door
I'm a gentleman this is too much I ain't
one of these Superstar players oh hell
no I smelt the setup what will stop me
in my tracks real quick this one I think
somebody trying to remember get your ass
in your hotel room close that door
refraine
[Laughter]